why is it sequels always feel they have
to do the exact same thing they did in
the first one they already did in the
first one why would we want to see it
again national treasure - almost falls
into that trap there's yet another
treasure they had to find others yet
another bad guy who wants to get to it
first and there's yet another
controversy that they have to clear
their family name over as if that wasn't
bad enough we have our main characters
who now lost all the money that got in
the first film through some really dumb
explanation a scene where Nicolas Cage
has to win the girlfriend over again to
convince her of this crazy plot so they
can fall in love again and to make that
worse we have to do the exact same plot
with Jon Voight and his ex-wife Bess
repeating a storyline from the first one
twice but the good news is when the
mistery in the action does start it gets
fun again when the characters are all
together and trying to figure this all
out it's great and there's nothing wrong
with it it's still just as goofy it
finds more landmarks to find these
secret locations in there's more puzzles
more silly quests then there's more
trailer fodder like remember in the
first film wheezes I'm going to steal
the Declaration of Independence well now
this one is I'm going to kidnap Rose
United States yeah seems like that our
groaners and anytime they try to
recapture the set up of the first one it
fails and it's stupid and it's pointless
but again like the first one when they
try to focus on the actual treasure hunt
element it's still a lot of fun
it's still goofy it's still silly but
you still find yourself getting wound up
it then Harris is a good bad guy that's
Helen Mirren as the mother and yeah even
though they have her and john-boy
complain a lot when she's not doing that
she's a lot of fun I just don't get why
they had to separate these characters
and star Tom at square one again when
you don't really need to why couldn't
they keep the money and use some new
devices to find this stuff how come
nobody believes them again wouldn't it
make sense from the first film to
believe this guy that maybe he sounds
crazy he might actually be correct about
it but there's still some really good
decent scenes for example there's this
moment where the president is left alone
and like he said he kidnaps him
the conversations he has with em are
actually kind of fun and engaging I
really enjoy the dialogue where he talks
about the importance of his ancestors
and his family date I think it actually
doesn't much better here that doesn't
the first film but it pretty much leads
exactly where you think it's gonna lead
they find the treasure they even sort of
reveal the treasure in the same way with
lighting the torches the treasure kinda
looks the same as the first film but a
limit for the puzzle elements and the
adventure and the journey I still kind
of like it I can't bring myself to
actually say don't see it because all
the stuff that was good and the first
one is still good here at least when it
comes to the treasure hunt everything
else man it's not needed in my opinion
you could just cut out the first 20
minutes and go from there but you got to
take what you got ever what we got I
think it's ok it's not bad follow up but
not the best either give it a rent and
find out for yourself
you